[Music]
all right once again The Usual Suspects
on the left are seething and they're
brooding about the inherent awfulness of
another American tradition writing in
Psychology today Christopher Ferguson
notes that it's the season for
Thanksgiving and we can look forward to
some members of the glitterati giving
thanks by dumping on the holiday itself
we're told that the holiday celebrates
genocide and news articles repeat the
myth that the first Thanksgiving
celebrated a massacre of Native
Americans of course that's all absurd
the only thing that makes the left in
America truly happy this time of year
especially is grousing about how we're
all living I don't know on Stolen land
you who call yourself an activist an
ally an accomplice
for social justice we see you making
plans for Thanksgiving I don't celebrate
a proper Thanksgiving because the
cultural Demolition and genocide of the
indigenous people of this land is not
something I feel like celebrating
celebrating Thanksgiving is celebrating
racist genocide
gobble gobble
how about celebrate taking a shower
every now and then what a shame she
won't be joining your Thanksgiving table
but on the bright side most Americans
see all this complaining it's just
another exercise in self-loathing by
spoiled entitled ingrates and most
people will happily celebrate
Thanksgiving with family and friends
and as 2022 draws to a close the angle
is grateful for so much
number one
we defeated the man who was behind more
coveted lies than Hunter Biden was
behind prostitutes Dr Anthony fauci
always wrong but never in doubt had the
nerve to show himself at the White House
today
his Lounge Act is way past its
expiration date people who have correct
information who takes science seriously
who don't have strange way out theories
about things but who base what they say
on evidence and data need to speak up
more because the other side that just
keeps putting out misinformation and
disinformation seems to be tireless in
that effort and it's going to be very
difficult
more on that in a bit with his chief
Nemesis at the White House and one of
his targets but number two we're
grateful for all those parents who work
tirelessly to fight exposing the school
boards for being radical cesspools of
sexual deviancy and racial hatred
bathroom is still not safe for girls
porn books a steal on the Shelf of what
school libraries and the parents
parental rights are still being ignored
cultural marxists are hard at work to
brainwash our children focus on raising
our Rock Bottom test scores and do away
with exposing miners to sexually
explicit material where is the math
where is the reading where is the
history where are the strong values
now more responsible adults are running
for school board positions and refusing
to stay silent that's really great news
and politicians now know that parent
power it's a real thing
third
we're grateful that the defeat of for
the defeat of the woman who speaks like
she's kind of suffering from
appendicitis
we laid out very consistently and and I
think thoroughly including in our last
hearing where we walked through
president Trump's intent at each stage
of of this effort to overturn the
election
guys good riddance to the bush Cheney
years once and for all fourth
we're thrilled this Thanksgiving that
conservatives led by Ron DeSantis stood
up to Disney and other woke corporations
when those businesses turned on Middle
America
things had gone so far into the toilet
for Disney after it injected itself into
the gender fluidity issue that this week
we learned that the company was firing
its CEO and bringing back its retired
CEO Bob Iger to try to fix things
fifth despite ballot harvesting early
voting and everything else the Democrats
tried to do to game the system
Republicans won the popular vote in
house races for the first time since
2016.
now that happened in part because we saw
an exciting New Generation of populist
candidates running across the country
including Hispanics and African
Americans
sixth
for the second time in 12 years liberal
house Speaker Nancy Pelosi is going to
be forced to give the gavel to a new
Republican speaker now we're going to
miss her of course I can't say otherwise
especially her press conferences and her
assorted Antics and as a Catholic I
resent you're using the word hate in a
sentence that addresses me my whole
mission in Congress is about the
children for the children they're in the
arena you have to be prepared to take a
punch
have to be prepared to throw a punch for
the children
children
[Applause]
well the good thing for Nancy is now
she's going to have a lot of time on her
hands to do other important work
like pouring through that footage from
police body cams in our home security
system from the night her husband was
viciously attacked if anyone can get
answers there Nancy can
seventh we have huge gratitude for the
fact that the court finally ended the
scourge of Roe versus Wade
now this issue was never something that
should have been read into the
Constitution and now it's properly left
up to the states
we can all thank 50 years of hard work
on the part of the pro-life community
that never gave up never gave up on
standing for life
this outcome was worth it no matter what
the political Fallout period
eighth on the thankfulness list we
cannot forget the red State Governors
who continue to stand as a beacon of
sanity and common sense to the rest of
America as States like Illinois and
California they continue to bleed
population and breed crime well Florida
Texas South Dakota Tennessee Mississippi
Georgia they're doing it right
they led us by opening up during covid
and they're leading us still
Governor desantis's 20-point re-election
win was a stunner Florida's no longer a
swing state that's because of him
neither is Texas by the way flipping to
Democrat anytime soon Governor Greg
Abbott and Lieutenant Governor Dan
Patrick both cruised to re-election
knife
thank you to Lee zeldin's Strong run for
Governor New York the GOP flipped four
seats in the Empire State with more to
come in 2024.
now this was a big step and everyone
should send zeldon a thank you note for
campaigning as hard as he did
and in the Golden State liberals felt
the heat when we won 11 seats in the
house with one more that still hasn't
been called
next the governorship of California and
the State House races we got to start
somewhere though
and culturally on the Gratitude scale
there were some bright spots as well
which leads me to number 10.
more adults finally see the inherent
evil in butchering children's
reproductive organs and messing with
their hormonal makeup
we're seeing hospitals like Vanderbilt's
transgender Health Clinic pressured into
stopping these surgeries for children
and states are taking action to ban
these surgeries for minors in their own
areas altogether Alabama Arizona they've
already have bans in place on gender
affirming care and that's for kids and
many more plan to follow suit
if we're successful in stopping these
quote surgeries on children
we're going to hear fewer painful
stories like this
I was 12 year old 12 years old when I
first started to experience gender
dysphoria pretty much all the medical
professionals
kept pushing the idea that um
transition is the only path forward to
treating dysphoria
wow 11th on the thing the thankfulness
list we're now seeing even some on the
left waking up to the reality of and the
danger of tick tock Donald Trump was
right I mean Tick Tock is a enormous
threat if you're a parent and you got a
kid on Tick Tock I would be very very
concerned all of that data that your
child is inputting and receiving is
being stored somewhere in Beijing
by the way Mike Pompeo said this in 2020
on the Ingram angle
and we're even seeing cultural victories
at the box office we're thankful for Top
Gun where Maverick was the highest
grossing film of the year the fifth
highest grossing movie of all time
bringing in
1.44 billion at the box office worldwide
now this movie was at its core kind of a
tribute to the Reagan Era when we had no
hesitation remember about calling out
communism and standing for the USA
Captain Pete Maverick Mitchell let me be
perfectly blocked you are not my first
choice you were here at the request of
Admiral kazanski AKA Iceman he seems to
think that you have something left to
offer the Navy
what that is I can't imagine
with all due respect sir I'm not a
teacher I just want to manage the
expectations
and finally on a personal note I have an
enormous amount to be grateful for first
my children
two teenagers and one on the cusp while
they make life worth living day in and
day out
and of course my real friends who love
and support us all of us as a family
unconditionally
and come on my Ingram angle crew all of
them I love each and every one of them
it takes a lot to put on the show every
night and I'm just the one that you see
on camera but we all together make it
work I'm so grateful for all of them
and finally I'm grateful for all of you
the viewers who've been with us from the
very beginning and who stay with us
night after night as we try to inform
and entertain all at the same time
thank you
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else